do you think you ever got gas lit as a
kid of course my mom she would do the
thing where she goes I told you but in
my head I'm like I don't think you told
me but she's so confident that I'm like
I think she told me I guess you did
maybe I forgot I don't think they're
gaslighting I think they have a very
strong imagination they believe it I
think they believe it too Asian parent
delusion is on the line of uh psychotic
like how your dad said he never hit you
oh yeah I called my dad 3 weeks ago he
was like no I don't know why Jason's
like that he had the best
childhood like ever and my wife like
seen my yeah I don't want to no it's
okay go to a dark place you should go to
the dark place tell us the details you
just you literally said nothing you said
I have a story it started and then it
ended you're a good interrogator man
basically uh it's just we're out of time
we're going to have to tune in around
thank you guys for joining us